SAND, BOTH GOTTEN
TH, REPELY AU DISAGREE WHETHERRO
LET'S START THE DEBATE ASKING  H
TWO CAN ENGAGE
YORK CHAPING MTE
D SSES AND
GHT SOUNO SWEEPING FOR PLE BU RS
CCINATED.
ARES AND ONF TSVACCINATED
ES THE VACNE
>> I BELIEVE IT DOES.LL, PU IHIN
THE HISTOR COUNTRY H
GENERALLY BEEN LEFT UNS.
THE STATES AND LOCALITIES,UT
IT HAS BEEN LOOKED AN
EDION EFFO
SYSTEMS.
TO PUT THIS INTO THE THINGS.
ONE S RESISTANCE, THAT'S
WHAT WE SEE INRKI THINK ACROSS .
SECONDLY, THE TSE STRUCK
IT DOWN, BLARGE, THEIDENT'S MAN
MANDATES ARE UNCONSTTS
LOAT IT IN THAT FASHION.
ITBI CASE T COME CITY,
THAT'S A GNMT CLOSEST TO
BUT IF YOU'RE LOOKIN 1
STRUGGLING WITH WORKERS,U GE% VS
SERVICE PRERS, THEY'RE FOTHU
DON'TO
UNEMPLOY US IN TRYING  DO OU
E TH
Y STRUGGLINGVEN
IN THE HEALTREF PUT THAT IN,'RG
WORKERS AS WELL.
S PARTF ONS THATE OPASIO?
>>OVERNOT TO
YOU'RE DEALING WITH THIS CRISI
YOU TO KNOW THE
PEOPLE IAR O
>> THANKOU>> T THINGS RECOVER QU
GOVERNRIGH I FEAR.
OMICRON IS HE,ALE COUNTRY.
EST. HAVE  MOVE AN
TELL YOU WHA
BUSINESS COMMUNITY THAT THEIR
GREA SHUTDOWNS.
ST FEA GOING E WE WERSTE LOSINGH
WINTERTO SUPER
CHARGE COVID AND
BACKWARDS.
IO E
NCE T MANDATES I
ITY, SRT'VE SEEN OVER 1  DOSES.
VACCINATED.
DECISION BECAU T MANDATE W
PEOPLE ARE HAVE S INAT
TO TAKE ALL OF THE FACTORS I
UTROVEN THAT OR NOWAIT ENEMWIS .
WE'VT RATEGY TO >> GOVERNOR?
>>AYDENSITR OT HAS CHALLENGEB
YO UNTRY.VE GOTG TO SCHOOL EVK
CCN
AGREEMENT,'SNCE THE
H DYOU GET THERE? ME, WE' ROW
DIVIDING OUR COUNTRY ON THIS
BUT ON THE ISSUE OCCBY AARGEREP
ARKANSATOWN MEETINGS AL
BRINGINATION
EFFORTS, ENCOURAGING THAT, BUT
VE PARTICULARLY
PEOPLH ONLY
BY THEDA HAVE WE MANAT
VACCINE ATS EARL
.
VACCATU CAN TAKE TTED MAKE THE O
THLV
EQUIREF THEIR S TO BED, BUS LETL
THEY WANT  GO, BUT TO PUT E
E IN ID.IT'SNGO CAUSE HARDSHIPGN
COUNTRY, ACAY SE
AND SO THAT'S THE REASON INKE M
SIONCOTR W , L I
GRAPPLG  YOU.
SAYINGT
EMPLOY AAN HAVE THE RIGHT IF THS
UNDERSTANDABLY, WE DON'TAVA
PRECEDENT HERE.
WEE
ABSOLUTELY AN UNPRECEDENTED ISI'
INTO YEAR THREE OF THIS.VERNOR,.
TIMESHE COVID ERA
IF WE  HERE'S WHATR.SUE
T SES, SMALLS I'VEALWEE ANOTHER
MOM AND STORES CAN'TAFRDID
T AND
ITOS
O OURELLO
YOU TALK TSOMEONE LOST A
T, THNGS
ON THIS POINT, LOOK AT WHA
NDE
N D THEYNOLS ARE SAFE,RESTAURAN
YONE'SCITET'TUT THEM THRIVING
WHILE IND LEVELS
LOWOULDN'T WE WANT THAT FOERYON?
G IS YOURCCN NEW YORK
>> DID YETTO 90%?TES WENINTO>> B
>> ABOUT7% BEFORE THSTARTED IN Y
IDENTS, THAT
SINCE WE PUT THES IN KNOW, WE SO
OFPL
ECSE
EMPLOYEES.INE PRIVATE OR, THOUG
OUGHAVE THE
ABLE TATION
PEOP OW YORKD AN'VE
IT,  UNDERSTAND THAT
D  IN RISKNATION
OF CCESS., E GOINU HAVE
ATES A .NOW WHAT T
SEENT RESISTANCE
HERS A THAT'S  'RE GOING TO SEES
T THAT INTPLACE, A
SO TR CAN MAKE
THAT DECISION AS
WHETHER THEY WT VA
EIR EMPLOYEES,OPLE ARE GOIO ONST
DIVIDE AGAIN OAN
HOPE THAT WEORTHER
TO INCREASVAINONE A T
CITY VOLUNTABUT E
NDATES I THINK YOU'LL SEE ARE
GOIN
SE EN
GOINTOIT
NEED TO GEATED BY L
DECEMBER 27th,AF
CHRISTMAS.
CITY  ALL BUSINESSES INEW
DD ITHT VACCINATED?
OMD  ALL THE WE DID  OF CHRIS E
THITPRATCTOR
ALREADY WITHEST, FITNESS, AND WT
FOLLOWED THROUGH.
THEY MAY NOT HAVE THOUGHT THWOU
THEY ULTIMATELY THAT SHOT, ANDE
LOVED TO HAVD THIS  CUSTOMERS HE
IS FROM RESTAURANT
LL NOW.O  TLLAFE S BEENGOOD
.
WH BUSINESS IS TF SHUTDOWND REST
I'VE GOT BUSINS OWNERSRRIFIED TT
BACK WHE WGHT NO
TO YOU,R, I HT  A F
BUT RIT  IF FOR EXAMPLE INASF F
VACCINATEDUN OF COVID G OF
HUNDREDS OOFNGHE
OU OWEOFI'LENGING
HE TIME. ORONG CINT
NOW.
>> GOVERNOR NSON, FROU
>> JUSD THAT'S
RS, D